[Music]
so you're an American defense contractor
like Raytheon or Lockheed Martin let's
get something very clear you are in the
business of violence and the business
model is simple the more war the more
conflict the more Revenue you make
billions of dollars selling your state
of the art weapons to countries all over
the world but let's be honest these past
couple years business has been down at
the height of the Cold War in the Soviet
Union's invasion of Afghanistan
contracts for revolutionary and
expensive aircraft and weapon systems
were flooding in every second so you
were swimming in money but then the
Soviet Union collapsed and things
changed suddenly the world got peaceful
and sure the war on terror brought you a
boost in sales but it was nothing like
your cold war Glory Days not to mention
what the Soviet Union gotten and all
this new Global cooperation countries
like China Russia and pretty much all of
Eastern Europe started taking some of
your market share during the Cold War
buying weapons from the Soviet Union or
red China was Unthinkable they were the
enemy but after 1991 that all changed
suddenly it went wasn't anti-American to
buy guns and ammo from Russia or Eastern
Europe anymore they were affordable and
reliable you lost your Monopoly on a
market you used to dominate long story
short by the early 2000s Life as a
defense contractor sucked you're making
chump change compared to just 10 years
ago and you're desperate to get back to
the good old days when your products
were the only ones being bought but if
you're ever gonna get back to the top
again if you're ever gonna make real
money again you're gonna have to find a
way to force countries to buy your
weapons no matter how much you charge
for them you gotta find ways to make
them buy for you even though they're not
at War and the best way to do that NATO
expansion of course it's simple you see
NATO started out as a military alliance
against the Soviet Union but when the
Soviet Union finally collapsed NATO was
left without a real purpose but instead
of Fading Into the background It Came
Out Swinging and placed itself at the
Forefront of what's called European
cooperation countries could join NATO
and benefit from a long list of shared
services security and trade and all they
had to do was promise to only buy
weapons from certain manufacturers
spoiler alert most of those
manufacturers are American and the
reasoning actually makes sense if we're
gonna be in a military Alliance we
should all have the same standardized
gear and weapons and ammo that way if
war did break out American soldiers in
the European counterparts have all been
trained on the same Gear with the same
weapons the same ammo calibers the same
expensive armored vehicles the same
fighter jets and so forth so the more
NATO expands the more countries that
join NATO for safety from Russia or
China or whatever the more you stand to
make because they all have to buy from
you so obviously as an American defense
contractor you are incentivized to get
as many countries to join NATO as
possible and luckily we're here to take
you through every step you need to
become a NATO War profiteer my name is
Jake Trent and we make documentaries on
money power war and crimes so that you
can see the world for what it really is
a giant game of acquiring power you
can't get out of this game either way so
instead of being a victim why not learn
to be a better player your parents
teachers friends Society will never
teach you any of this so we're going
stay dangerous and this is how to profit
from NATO expansion
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
one country that's increasing its
defense spending right now is Japan
because of the China threats which makes
American war profiteers drool from their
mouths Japan is the world's 12th largest
arms importer and most of what it buys
comes from America that's why in July
Reuters reported that Raytheon was
already lobbying Japan to ditch Lockheed
Martin to buy their 300 million radar
systems instead lobbying money well
spent if the deal goes through and I
learned all this from the super
informative newsletter called The Daily
upside the daily upside is a free yes
completely free business and investing
newsletter founded by a team of
financial professionals that over 750
000 people subscribed to what sets the
daily upside apart from other free
newsletters is that their stories are
short and sweet enough to where you're
able to get the latest information fast
every single morning but it's not too
short to where you're not getting any
useful insights just like the Japan
defense spending story I share with you
and there's none of the BS you get with
mainstream media I personally love the
daily upside and sometimes I even get
video ideas from the stories they cover
and the best part is that again it free
so you should definitely pause the video
and sign up for free right now with the
link below it takes like 10 seconds to
sign up and you have nothing to lose
pause the video and click the link below
now thanks to the Daily upside for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
if president milosevic will not make
peace we will limit his ability to make
war
as an American defense contractor war is
where you make the most of your money in
peacetime countries usually have long
relaxed schedules when it comes to
ordering and actually paying for weapons
and equipment some of these contracts
can last years and that means you don't
really get one big payday instead you
get paid in tiny installments over a
massive period of time not ideal but
during war most of your regular
customers are so anxious under so much
pressure that they're begging you to
send them everything you've got as
quickly as possible America spends over
800 billion dollars on its military
every year that's almost as much as
Saudi Arabia's entire GDP in comparison
the second biggest military spender in
the world is China standing at around
290 billion dollars a year less than
half of what America spends so it's no
surprise that war is when the potential
for big money really appears and
although you'll deny it till the day you
die you like War you need War war is
when you're at your Peak but that's not
all because if war is brewing and your
cards fall just right Russia will
inevitably get involved and that's when
the dollars really start flowing in
because once Russia picks aside in a
fight you can bet the other side will be
running to Nato to ask for help Russia
is like the big bad bully in the
schoolyard and NATO is that one strict
teacher that always knows how to put the
bully back in their place
by joining me countries all over the
world can hide behind their big bad
members like America and Western Europe
and avoid being obliterate before Russia
invaded Ukraine only 20 to 30 percent of
people in Finland wanted their country
to join NATO now that number sits at
over 70 percent that's why none of
America's defense contractors ever seem
worried about messing up the world's
relationship with Russia or provoking
conflict all over Europe because one way
or another you know conflict is going to
add to your bottom line
[Music]
you know that there were some in
Congress maybe my friend is included in
that who think that it's acceptable to
give this Administration a blank check
to continue these endless Wars
[Music]
the possibility of War especially war
with Russia is naturally going to make
countries run to Nato for Safety and
Security but for an ambitious defense
contractor like yourself that's just not
enough you want to milk every Conflict
for everything it's worth because who
knows once war ends and things get quiet
it could be years before another
conflict explodes years before you get
to expand your customer base so to make
the most of the benefits NATO offers you
have to go on a lobbying campaign like
no other basically you have to donate
money to American politicians in the
hopes that they'll see things your way
wink wink in the seven years after the
Soviet Union collapsed defense
contractors spent over 32 two million
dollars on lobbying Congress members and
candidates in comparison the tobacco
industry one of the biggest and most
evil Industries when it comes to
lobbying in propaganda only spent around
26 million dollars in the same time
period now they'll say that not all of
that lobbying cash was spent to
encourage NATO expansion but it was
definitely their biggest ask and that's
not all once you're pouring money into
American government's officials Pockets
to encourage NATO expansion you have to
hit them on the emotional front too
remember logic stirs the audience an
emotion wins people's hearts you have to
make the American government feel guilty
for not doing enough for not preparing
for a war with Russia that you in your
expert opinion know is coming a accuse
the Pentagon of ignoring the fact that
quote Russian aggression is on NATO's
doorstep
make them think Russia's every move is a
sign of impending conflict that way the
American government will think the only
safe move is to push for more countries
to join NATO while the rest of Europe
will be lining up to be the first ones
accepted into the group then all you
have to do is go one step further and
remind the world in NATO that the only
way to counter their big bad neighbor to
the east is with massive military
spending which you'll be very happy to
help them out with
we have reached today an important
decision in good cooperation between the
government and the president of the
Republic we hope that the parliament
will confirm the decision to apply for
NATO membership during the coming days
once the world agrees the only way to
keep the peace is by expanding NATO
that's when your marketing team needs to
step in with the big guns literally
be like Tony Stark and go to the guys in
power and show them just how good how
Cutting Edge how state of the art your
weapons really are the American
government NATO and American defense
contractors already have a symbiotic
relationship so it won't take long for
them to add your list of products and
services to their requirements you see
joining NATO isn't just as easy as
filling in an application form and
waiting to be approved it takes a lot of
work from the countries who want to join
they have to make policy changes
sometimes they have to change some of
their laws but the requirement you're
the most concerned with is the mandatory
military upgrades in spending
get in and stay in each NATO hopeful has
to spend at least two percent of its GDP
on its military and defense abilities
and that's where the big money really
comes from
take Denmark for example it's GDP in
2021 was nearly 400 billion dollars as
part of NATO it has to spend at least
eight billion dollars of that income on
its military and Finland the NATO
hopeful where 70 percent of the
population now wants to join the
organization well if they want to get in
they'll have to start spending at least
six billion dollars of their 300 billion
dollar GDP on weapons and Military
expansion too Finland has already
ordered 64 War points that cost over 110
million dollars each just to have a
better chance at finally being led into
NATO and who are the preferred
manufacturers of NATO weapons and
Military products American defense
contractors of course
just this year Estonia and Norway bought
1.5 billion dollars worth of weapons
from American Military contractors just
imagine the profit potential if all of
Europe joined NATO
a good chunk of that Newfound military
spending will automatically flow into
your pocket and the best thing yet even
if countries are too poor to afford your
expensive weapons and military equipment
that's not a problem at all because the
American government offers a quick and
easy solution military aid
doctors have approved 40 billions
President Biden today signing a
bipartisan 40 million dollars
right now Ukraine's government is
hemorrhaging money all over the place
they have refugees to feed soldiers to
train infrastructure to rebuild and
massive military spending to support and
let's face it sometimes there just
aren't enough dollars to go around
which sucks if you're a defense
contractor looking to make big bucks
from the war
luckily the American government always
looks after its own
so to help Ukraine fight back and help
NATO member countries expand their
militaries even when they don't have
enough money to do it themselves America
will offer the military aid plus in 1996
defense contractor lobbyists actually
convinced the government to guarantee
NATO and Prospect of NATO countries
loans for defense purchases just this
year the American government has spent
more than 40 billion dollars on one
single War package to Ukraine but these
war and Aid packages aren't handouts
their loans forced loans Ukraine can't
choose what it wants to do with the
money or what weapons it needs but it'll
have to pay for it all anyway
do you know what that means that means
you get a forced customer thanks to your
big brother which is just another great
example of how the American government
looks out for its defense contractors
while still making itself out to be the
good guy the American plebs cover the
costs of the aid packages through taxes
an American defense contractors get paid
for the weapons they so graciously
provide and in the end the country being
helped out gets to spend decades trying
to pay back a loan it was forced to take
even though American defense contractors
didn't make as much money from the war
on terror there were still many people
that got filthy rich off of him but
here's something you may not know the
war on terror and all the worst Terror
events of the last few decades can all
be traced back to one culprit and that
culprit is America
see in 1953 the CIA changed the history
books they overthrew the democratically
elected prime minister of Iran Muhammad
mosedek because as you probably guessed
mosadeg got in the way of American and
British prophets at first it looked like
the more successful CIA operation ever
but little did they know that this one
small Act of aggression this one coup
would be the first Domino the first
butterfly that would lead to some of the
worst acts of Terror in history and
arguably a lot of the conflict between
America and the Middle East today here's
the thing though a public video that
goes into all the details of Iran and
acts of Terror would definitely get
demonetized right away so instead we've
released an exclusive private
documentary on the Iran coup that's only
available to members of this Channel all
you have to do to get access to our
video on CIA black sites as well as
loads of other topics like our latest
one on the connection between Victoria's
Secret and everyone's favorite Private
Island owner every jepskin is to hit the
join button below people spend years of
their life and tens of thousands of
dollars to attend University only to
leave not knowing anything about how the
world really works but by becoming a
member you'll get access to all this
Insider info for only five dollars a
month and trust us it's way more
entertaining than University lectures
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most YouTube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
for the first time and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund
don't you just love some good old war
profiteering but in all seriousness do
you know how everyone in this world is
pretty much after power but everyone is
afraid to admit it well that is the
point of this channel we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can learn from these
power games instead of becoming a victim
to it so if that sounds interesting to
you click that subscribe button below we
make multiple videos just like this one
every single week for free so you have
nothing to lose and everything to gain
but that is going to wrap it up thanks
for being part of the watch that end
Club stay dangerous out there and I will
see you guys in the next one
foreign
[Music]